I guess I want to be remembered or
anything it's 44 sort of introducing a
different way of thinking about the
world about war about human rights about
equality for getting more and more
people to think that way and also for
getting more people to realize that the
power which rests so far in the hands of
people with wealth and guns that the
power ultimately rests in people
themselves and that they can use it and
at certain points in history they have
used it black people are South used it
people in the women's movement used to
people in the anti-war movement used it
people in other countries who have
overthrown tyranny have used it and I
want yeah so I want whether you remember
is somebody who gave people a feeling of
hope and power that didn't have before
you